nous avons transmis notre
reine les couples un besoin à la russie
travaille tout le temps pour renforcer
notre défense à présent et pour les
années à venir
partenaire la géorgie la finlande et
l'union européenne se sont également
joints à la première session
le ministre
ukrainien de la défense kick off
décrit la mort et la destruction causée
par la guerre a tenté par le président
poutine
l'assistance
la résistance résolue d'ukrainiens
contre l'invasion
l'importance de notre soutien et de la
poursuite de ce soutien sont attitude
nous rendre hommage au courage du peuple
ukrainien
est dûe au courage des forces armées
craignant des alliés de l'otan et nos
partenaires ont soutenu le cren
par le biais d'équipement et de
formation pendant plusieurs années
espérons que les ukrainiens pourront
exercer leur droit à l'autodéfense à la
liberté et à la démocratie
[Musique]
nous avons fourni à l'ukraine des
quantités importantes équipes en 2008
militaires sont convenus aujourd'hui que
nous devions poursuivre ce soutien à
l'udc notamment par la fourniture
d'équipements militaires à une aide
financière et par une aide militaire
les alliés et partenaires de l'otan ont
également consenti accueillez des
millions de réfléchir ingrédients ce
président poutine doit cesser cette
guerre sur le champ
doit retirer ses forces maintenant il
doit prendre part aux efforts
diplomatiques de bonne foi
réagit assez tech prise en faisant front
commun need
la semaine prochaine les chefs d'état de
l'otan se réuniront à l'occasion d'un
sommet extraordinaire
nous devons aborder les changements à
venir et notre réaction immédiate en vue
d'assurer notre sécurité collective
moscou ne doit pas se tromper l'otan ne
tolérera aucune attaque aucune atteinte
à la souveraineté et à l'intégrité
territoriale des pays de l'otan
nous avons déjà activé le plan de
défense pour protéger cuisent alliance
nous avons près hausser notre niveau d'
alerte et déployer des troupes des deux
côtés de l'atlantique
il ya à l'heure actuelle des centaines
de milliers d'hommes et de femmes en
état d' alerte dans tous les territoires
de l'alliance
cent mille soldats en europe et environ
quarante mille soldats commandement
direct de l'otan dans la partie
orientale de l'alliance
par des forces navales et aériennes
ainsi que par les défenses aériennes
nous sommes face à une nouvelle réalité
en terme de sécurité devons
réinitialiser notre sécurité collective
et notre dissuasion sur le long terme
aujourd'hui nous avons chargé notre
commandement militaire
d'élaborer de nouvelles options dans
tous les domaines sur terre sur mer dans
les airs et dans l'espace cybernétique
shooting plus notre chaussure doit
contre offre davantage de force dans la
partie orientale de l'alliance
l'état de préparation doit être réhaussé
et cela doit passer par davantage de
fourniture d'équipements dans les airs
davantage de puissance
force d'intervention davantage de
défense antimissile sur terre sur
boulogne-sur-mer
sous des maires des sous marins des
vaisseaux de combat dont la présence
doit être continu et envisageant
également l'avenir de notre cyber
défense
comment tirer parti de nos actifs juste
dans le cyberespace sites vont également
former davantage et nous entraîner plus
souvent
devons renforcer notre dissuasion et
cela nécessitera davantage
d'investissements les alliés doivent
investir au minimum 10 2% de leur pib
dans leur défense
et je me félicite des annonces faites
par l'allemagne le danemark des annonces
important indique davantage de
l'investissement
devront également dépensé davantage
ensemble
le financement commun de l'otan nous
permet de travailler chanson
c'est un multiplicateur de force pour
les efforts de défense
c'est une démonstration de solidarité en
tant qu'allié
à cette heure critique pour notre
sécurité
l'unité entre l'amérique et l'europe est
plus importante que jamais
je suis prêt à répondre à vos questions
la bbc au centre
merci monsieur
à nouveau écouter l'allocution de
monsieur dean ski qui appelait
d'exclusion aérienne le bénin est ce que
des alliés de l'otan ont appelé à une
telle exclusion
même si il n'y a pas d'intention de
faire appliquer cette exclusion il ya
t'il des discussions à ce sujet deuxième
question
l'ukraine a appelé
l'otan à envisager son adhésion
pour parvenir à un accord
en quelque sorte avec la russie
les alliés sont unis pour eux
apporté un soutien à l'ukraine afin de
faire valoir son droit à l'autodéfense
les alliés de l'otan sont également unis
pour ce qui concerne le fait que l'otan
ne doit pas déployer de forces sur
le terrain en ukraine et dans les airs
dans l'espace aérien on y croit car nous
devons veiller à empêcher la désescalade
escalade nous avons constaté la
destruction les souffrances humaines
mais cela peut empirer si
l'otan prend des mesures qui rendent
cette agression une guerre de grande
ampleur entre la russie et l'alliance
bien sûr nous devons
entretenir des modalités de soutien les
ministres de la défense ont souligné
l'importance de ce soutien des
équipements avancés des systèmes de
défense aérien des systèmes anti char et
d'autres types de soutien
ainsi que des déploiements de capacité
sur terre et dans les airs voilà notre
position unifiée entre alliés de l'otan
mais le message que nous adressons à
l'ukraine est le même que celui que nous
lui adressons depuis des années ukraine
est un état souverain qui a le droit de
choisir son sort
et ses décisions qui sont prises par un
gouvernement démocratiquement élu
doivent être respectés et cela doit être
respectée ce que l'ukraine soit ou non
anne alliés de l'otan
et ce n'est pas à la russie de s'opposer
à une telle souveraineté
merci monsieur secteur général cnn je me
demande si l'otan a invité le président
chavez qui appartenait à participer au
sommet extraordinaire des chefs d'état
de l'otan
et quelle est votre réaction à la
proposition de la pologne d'envoyer une
force de maintien de la paix sur le
territoire ukrainien
nous devons assurer la paix unique
rennes poutine doit arrêter
la guerre
nous devons parvenir les solutions
négociées et nous souhaitons tous les
efforts diplomatiques dans ce sens et
nous nous félicitons des pourparlers qui
ont lieu à l'heure actuelle entre
l'ukraine et la russie
et nous soutenons l'ukraine car nous
savons qu'ils peuvent parvenir et à des
résistants à la table des négociations
tout en progressant
les ukrainiens ont constaté des progrès
dans la bonne direction et cela est dû à
leur résistance
se sont défendus contre l'invasion des
forces russes leur courage leur
détermination et le soutien de l'otan
aux forces et ukrainiens sont
extrêmement importants quant à ce qui
peut être obtenu dans le cadre du
processus de négociations avec la russie
à nouveau
bien sûr que nous soutenons les efforts
de paix nous appelons la russie et le
président poutine a retiré ses portes
mais ne voue pas l'intention de déployer
des forces de l'otan sur le terrain en
ukraine
monsieur le secrétaire
général
des commentaires sur le rôle de l'italie
danse elle est jolie anniversaire
merci
l'italie
est un allié précieux de l'otan qui
contribue à nos efforts de défense
je ne suis récemment rendu en
roumanie j'ai rencontré des pilotes
italiens
sécurité de l'espace aérien de l'otan
ils ont fait preuve de leur engagement
et leur contribution importante au
lit est un allié clé depuis plusieurs
années
hoenheim